よろしくお願いします
今日の話は何か経典から引用して話すようになってましたけど
昨日何か経典を選びようと思ったんだけど
事務所の方が大変戦争みたいに忙しくて
で 私はいろいろ経典調べをすると
それは邪魔だから帰っちゃったんです
で あの昨日 あの英字新聞を読んでいると
このアメリカのあの子供二人が女の人
四人五人ぐらい殺しちゃったというケースがありまして
まあこの前もそれにニュース
テレビに出ただろうと思いますけど
で それからまあ子供たちが 12歳
3歳  13歳  14歳 その年の間では
まあもうかなり人を殺すケースがまあ目立っているんですね
で 人を殺すという大胆なことっていうのは
まあ昔風に考えちゃうと
よっぽどの人でないとできないことなんですね
これも可愛い子供たちやっちゃいますからね
で それは考えなくちゃいけないし
この間 この鈴木さんに言われましたけど
この大宝輪に記事があって
まあそれは見せてくれたんだけど
この大宝輪の記事っていうのは
まあなぜ人を殺してはいけないのかというテーマでしたし
私は読んでないんですけど
で ある小学生の子供が先生になぜ人を殺してはいけないのかと聞いたんだそうで
それでその先生も答えられなくなったと
ということから あの記事書いたお坊さんが一生懸命
まあこういうこういうわけで
決して殺してはいけないということを書いてるんです
そこでまあ 私も同じテーマで
なぜ人を殺してはいけないのかと
同じテーマで喋ろうとしているんです
どうせ皆様は知ってるんだから
まあテーマは決めるんだけど
内容っていうのは結構まあ普通の枠組みからまあ飛んでいきますからね
それは覚悟してお願いします
ほしいんです で それから今日の話から
私はこのいろんなことを話しますけど
皆様方に直接関係ないかもしれません
皆様はこちらで人を殺す人のどころか
人に悪口を言う人もいないし
で 大変いろいろ仏教の話を聞いたり
心清らかな仕事が一生懸命修行したりしているんだから
まあたとえ自分をいじめたっても
言い返ししないような心ができている人々だから
今日の話は直接は関係ないかもしれません
でも 皆様方は自分だけ良ければね
私たちの心はもう大丈夫だと
私たちは悪いことはしませんと
まあそれだけで気が済んじゃったらちょっと困るんです
私たちには なぜ私たちはこんなことをやるかということ
みんなにちゃんと説得できるように言える能力を持たないとダメなんです
例えば人がなんであんた瞑想するんですかと
インチキ臭いでしょうとかね
言われちゃったら冗談じゃないと
こういうこういうわけで
こういうこういうことで
私たちはこういうことをやるんだと
それやらないことこそインチキ臭いだというふうに言えるぐらいの
自分たちが自分をやっていることについて納得していかないと
もう世の中の役に立たないんですね
そういうことで 真剣に話を聞いて理解していただいて
まあ我々の周りの人々にも
この道徳的な生き方っていうのはちゃんと説得できるように教えなくちゃいけないということで
指導者の立場になって
今日の話を聞いていただきたいんです
単なる私の話を聞いて何か勉強しようではなくて
まあ皆様方も私もいくらかの指導者の立場になってもらって
で 話を聞いていただきたいんです
で 私はなぜ人を殺してはいけないのかと子供たちに聞いたら
皆様方は答えられますかね
そんな簡単な質問じゃないんですね
子供たちが聞いているのは
もし簡単な答えがあるんだったら
これだからやってはいけないよと言えるでしょうし
それぐらいのことっていうのは
大人よりは子供の方が頭しっかりしているんだから
もう簡単な答えあるんだったら知ってるはずなんです
大体まあ子供っていうのは勉強勉強真っ最中だから
脳細胞はフル回転しているんです
ですから 私たち想像するところよりはもうかなり物事を考えているんです
ですから まあ人を殺してはあかんと
こういうわけだと 単純明快な答えがあるんだったら
子供はもう聞かないんです
そこで大人がすぐ単純明快な答えを出すとするんですからね
答えがないと思います
私も そこで そう  そういうどんな子供か私はわかりませんだけど
私は象徴的にとって喋りますけど
例えば子供がある 子供がなぜ人を殺してはいけないのかと聞いたとする
その子供が何を聞いてるんですかね
道徳論を聞いてるんです
モラリティエティクスという英語でいう倫理学
ローマ字で書くならば
まあモラリティなんですね
モラルなんですね モラリティでいえば倫理学で
道徳でエティクスといえば倫理学なんですね
これは道徳論で これは倫理学
で 私たちは教育の世界できちんとしたある程度の合理的なことを教えているんですね
科学的な教えがもう大半だから
まあ全部まあ計算して
数字で実験して これでこういう結果になります
これでこういうことになりますとか
物理学やら化学やら まあそういうものはずっと教え込んでいるんです
ですから 子供たち考えられるのは理屈的なものしか考えられないんです
で 我々は教育を 現代教育では
まあものすごい まあ教育は徹底的な科学的で
教え方も何でもきちんといろんなことを考えて論理的に構成しているんです
ですから 小さい時からもう子供たちには何でもちゃんと理屈をつけてあげて
それこういうことでこういう結果になりますよと言っているんです
ですから 子供たちというのは現代人で入れ替えてもいいし
そこで 現代若い層の人々の頭っていうのは
まあ徹底的な理屈的なで成り立っているんです
それだったら 道徳にしても倫理学についても
ちゃんとした理屈に基づいた科学に基づいた教えでないとわからないんです
人殺してはいけませんとか
人のものを取ってはいけませんと
病気が悪るのは良くないんだとか
そんなこと言ったっても
あれなぜでしょうかと聞きたくなるのは
私はごく普通自然だと思います
ということは 我々大人が
ちゃんと道徳を教えていない
そこら辺考えていない
考えたこともない これ危ないことなんです
科学やら医学やら生物学やらああだこうだとか
ものすごい厳密に明確に教えるならば
なんで道徳もそのようにしっかりした論理に基づいて
科学的な思考に基づいて喋らないのかと
で 教育者は考えたことはないでしょうね
そんなことは ということは
私の考え方で言えば で
微生物 細菌やらね 微生物など体に入ったら体は病気になりますよと
ということは 子供たちは当たり前のことと知っているんです
どうやって生命が誕生するかということは
最近性教育も教えているんだから
小さい時から子供たちはもうちゃんと知っている
それには疑問しないでしょうね
小さな子供は別として
だいたい小学校に行く子供たちが
まあ人間というのは本当に拾うもんだですかと聞かないんです
私が まあ私ではなくて
他の子供 小さい時でも
まあ子供たちは私はどこから来たんですか？と
もう拾ったんですよと言ったんです
言われたんです で それで疑問もしないで
まあそうですかということで終わったんだけど
今の子供たちはそんな質問もしないし
知ってるんですから どのような働きで子供が生まれるかという真実を語っているんです
ですから 別に問題なくそこら辺は理解している
なんでそれだったら人殺してはいけないというふうなことを当たり前の論理として教えられないんですかね
花に花が咲いたら あの
まあちょっと日本語のことはわかりませんだけど
この花粉がね 花のあるところにつけるでしょうに
まあそうすると ちゃんとその花の中で
あの種が出来上がるということ
構成がね 全部明確に教えているし
ちゃんと明確に教えちゃったならば
子供は何のために花が咲くんですか？と
そんな馬鹿な質問一度も聞かないと思います
もう知ってるんです 何のために花が咲くんですかと
何のために種があるんですかと
ということは なんで人殺しはいけないかと聞くならば
我々は教えていないということになるんですね
で 私が言いたいのは 科学の世界で
まあ論理的な世界で 我々はきちんと教えるものは
それは当たり前だと そういうことだと風に説得して教えているならば
なぜ倫理学 道徳の場合はそういうふうに教えられないかと
ですから そこは大変な問題なんです
その社会問題は今表れているんです
で そこでこのまあ話の入り口なだけなんですけど
で これで言いたいのは
我々に道徳というもの
いいことをしましょう
悪いことをやめましょうということも
科学みたいにもうきちんと成立して喋られるかと
今まで喋ったことあるかということを最初に考えましょう
私の結論は いまだに誰もちゃんと道徳を整理して喋っていない
いい加減に喋っているという結論なんです
ずいぶんいい加減ではないかと
それからちょっと歴史的なヒストリカルバックグラウンドですが
歴史的な背景から あの道徳というものをちょっと考えましょう
で 人類の歴史の中でずっと
まあじわじわといろんな道徳概念は生まれてきたんです
例えば 人殺しはいけないという概念は
今 今もこの武器が随分増えているんだからできたことじゃないんです
子供はバタフライナイフ使ってるんだから
人殺しはいけないという概念生まれたわけじゃないし
アメリカだったらみんな鉄砲使ってるんだから生まれた概念ではないんです
昔からあったんです 道徳はね
まあ人のものを盗んではいけませんとか
で 歴史を見ると見えることは
道徳は喋るんだけど 守る人は少なかったんではないか
よく喋ります 古い本なんか見たら
もうほとんど道徳ばっかしなんです
お説教ばっかしなんです
一番古い本というものは
ほとんど宗教本でしょうね
世の中で一番古いテキストっていうのは
アヴェスタというゾロアスター教宗教の経典なんです
まあそれからヴェーダ経典がありまして
それから旧約聖書も一部一部古い部分がありまして
まあ紀元前3000年になっちゃうと
ヴェーダ経典とウパニシャッドまでもうヴェーダ経典全部成り立ってるんで
全部宗教の本なんです
だから宗教というのは全部道徳を喋っている教えなんですね
でも そういう紀元前4000年前から
もう 3000年前から
もうそのその文明の中で道徳は喋ってきたんだけど
どうも歴史の流れを見ると人間守ってないでしょ
だから 何やってるんですかと
何やってきたんですかと
この人類は 口先だけで人殺しはいけないという
でも実際には人殺すと
そこで嘘つきでしょうに
たとえいくら聖書とか宗教の聖典とか何とかあったっても
じゃあそれを信じている人々はきちんと道徳的に正しく生きてきたんですかというと
全然ないんですね 歴史を見ると
だからまあ 今の人間だけじゃなくて
昔からも人間何やってきたんですか？自分が何か言ったならば
それはしっかりと実行してほしいし
実行してないんです だから
まあものすごい自由な思考で言えるならば
こういうありとあらゆる聖書群
いろんな宗教で それからいろんな道徳的な
もう説教を書いている古い文献というのは
結局みんな嘘つきじゃないかと
そうでなきゃ 我々の古い人々がきちんと行儀よく生きてきたはずなんです
でも 我々にもそう言うんです
昔の人は随分よくできた人間ですよと
あれは真っ赤な嘘なんです
ちゃんと歴史を子供たち勉強しているんだから
歴史にあるのは全部人殺し屋の歴史でしょうに
歴史にはほとんど残ってないんです
人間を作った人々のことやら
人間のために大変なことをした人々やら
正直な心で清らかに もうみんなに助け合って
もう静かない静かに生活した人々のものは全然記録していないんです
記録しているのは どれぐらい
何王様がどれぐらい人を殺したかとかね
どれぐらい他の国を侵略したんですかとか
ナポレオンとかアレクサンダーとか
あんなくだらない連中の話ばっかりでしょうに
日本の歴史も同じでしょうに
日本の一般国民が一生懸命畑耕して
自分の家族を守って まあよく頑張って生活しましたよということは書いてますかね
全部人 いかに人殺したかと
何人殺したかと 誰を誰が攻めたんですかと
どんな国はどんな軍隊がいて
どんな大名がいてやったかとかね
そういう歴史でしょうに
ですから ずいぶん人間
ずいぶん勝手に 全く無責任で
古い人々は良かったとか
道徳あったとか よく言うもんなんです
だからもう目を覚めてほしいんです
昔もテキストはあるんだけど
誰一人も実行していない
世の中にある歴史っていうのは
血の流れの歴史なんですね
どのように血が流れたかと
どのように弱い人は殺されてきたんですかと
そこで弱い人を殺しちゃって
強い人が国を作ったことは英雄だ
ヒーローだと あの人はその国を全部まとめて一つにしてくれたんですと
ですから 我々の偉大なるヒーローですよと
そんなことを教えちゃったら
子供たちももう弱いんだから我慢してるんだけど
じゃあ私もやるぞと言ったらどうします？そんなに他の人の国を攻めることでヒーローになるんだったら
じゃあ私たち現代子供たちが大きくなったら
片っ端から隣の国々と戦争して
全部日本の国土にしちゃおうしてヒーローになるんだと
それで歴史に残るんだというと
それはそうです やったらその人の名前は歴史に残るんです
いいことをしたら歴史から捨てるんです
抹消するんです ですから
今でもニュースに載りたければ
みんなに知られたければ
簡単な方なんですかね
悪いことすること いくらいいことをしたっても認めてくれないんです
勲章をもらうのは 97歳ぐらいになったところなんですね
例えば ずいぶん日本の国民に対して一生懸命献身的で
いろんなことをやったならば
97歳ぐらいになって
もうそろそろ来年ぐらい死ぬだろうと思ったら
嫌々で勲章をあげるんです
あれは 30歳で 40代
絶対あげないんです あるいは外国で見てみて
ノーベル賞を決めちゃったら
もう焦って勲章を決めるんですね
それだけ悪いことをしちゃったら
1日にしてもう日本中もう人気者というか
もう知られていると これ
日本だけの問題じゃなくて
アメリカのことでも 子供はまあ学校に入って
女の人に裏切られちゃったと
裏切られたんじゃなくて捨てられたんだと
まあ英語でダンプという言葉で書いてますから
この捨てられたんだからお腹が立って
組んで 2人でもうみんな殺してしまったと
それだったらまあ世界中ニュースに載るんです
だから悪いことをしたしかニュースに載らないし
歴史に残らないし それって道徳ですかね
それでまた道徳をうんうんと言うんです
だからなぜ人を殺してはいけないかと堂々と聞く子供たちというのは
素晴らしいと思います
あの人々は我々に何か言ってるんだと
いかに大人がっていうのは馬鹿もんだと
嘘つきだと言ってることなんです
そこでまあ こういうことを考えられる
ありとあらゆる聖書郡があって
道徳だったら 仏教の聖典を見ても
キリスト教の聖典を見てもそんな差がないんです
キリスト教でも欲張るなと
金持ちに天国行くことは
ラクダが針の針の穴を通るぐらい難しいんだと言ってるし
仏教でも欲こそがもう堕落の道だと言ってるし
似ているんです 一つのほっぺたを殴っちゃったら
もう一つをあげな もうその人にはこちらもどうぞと言いなさいというのは
イエス様の教えで 怒りは決して怒りでは消えませんと
慈しみの優しい心でしか消えませんというのはお釈迦様の教え
似ていること で でも誰も実行しない
一つ考えられるんです
もしかすると そういう道徳を喋った人々は
まあなんか喋らなきゃつまらないかと思って
無責任で好き勝手に言ったか
だからまあうわごとみたいにいろんなことを言いましたと
ですから説得力なかったと
何か言いたいんだから言っただけですよと
なんかもうイライラしたんだから
僕はずっと聖書みたいなものはもう神に言ってくれたんだと嘘を書いたんだと
あれも嘘ですから 神に聞いて書いたわけじゃないんだけどね
それは一つ 道徳を作った人々が真剣ではなかったという概念の
わかりやすく言えば まあただ遊びみたいな感じで書いたんではないかと
あるいは いえ 違いますよと
そういう道徳的な文献を書いた人々は
本当に真剣 真面目に言ったんだよと言われたとすると
じゃあそれ聞いた人々が
社会人が真面目に受けていなかったと
宗教が現れて 宗教やらいろんな道徳的な教えが
まあヨーロッパ ギリシア
あーだこうだ いろんなところにありますから
中国にもあるし どこにでもあります
あるんだけど そういう作った人々は真剣
真面目でしたけど 聞く社会はいい加減に聞かなかったかと
どっちがなんです もしその人々が
社会が 宗教家が言うことは真剣に聞いたとするならば
あ 素晴らしいと聞いたとするならば
なんで道徳を守らなかったんですかと
そこで出てくる問題は
それだったら人間というのは自分の都合によって道徳を守ったのではないかと
都合が良ければ守ると
都合が悪いんだったら守れませんと
それで道徳ですかね 得するんだったら嘘言わないんだと
損するんだったら嘘をつきますよと
そんなもんで道徳成り立つんですかね
私は殺されないならば
で 殺すことで私は得するんだったら殺してやるぞ
人殺しちゃったら損になるんだったら
私は人殺ししませんよと
そんなもんで道徳ですかと
ですから 過去の人々が結局自分の都合によって道徳を守ったり犯したりしてきてではないかというふうな質問も出てくるんです
ですから 古い人だからといって
まあただ古いなと 先祖たちですよと
偉い人々ですよと言っても
別に尊敬する必要はないんです
やったこと悪いんだったら
誰がやったって悪いんだから
だから僕は平気で 今までの全ての人類に生きてきた全ての文化に
文明にこのチャレンジをしているんです
あなた方はインチキ者ではなかったんですかと
嘘つきではなかったんですか
誰かわからない 宗教家か
その社会かと で まあお釈迦様のことちゃんと記録してしっかりしていますけど
例えばイエス様のことをしたっても
本当にその方がしっかりと自分の道徳を守ったか
あちこちちょっと遊んだりしたかどうかわからないんです
なんとなくちらちらとそういうことも出るんです
聖書を読むと ですから
まあ別にイエス様に悪口必要ないんだけど
とにかくあの 道徳を喋った人々がいい加減に喋ったか
インチキでしたかということ
その人々は本物であったならば
真面目な人々であったならば
社会は真面目に受け入れなかったということになっちゃうんです
そこで社会は真剣に真面目に受け入れなかったならば
その問題はどちらにあるんですか？社会人が悪かったか
教え方が悪かったか どっちでしょうね
社会人が大馬鹿者であれほど政治聖者たちが真理を語っているのに
もうわからなかったというならば
まあそれはそれで それで私が言いたいのは
もし聖者たちが道徳倫理を語っているのに
社会人が全然納得いかないのならば
やっぱりそれは先生の責任でしょうに
子供たちにはさっぱり理解できないというならば
子供たちが悪いと一概に言えますかね
教えるのは先生の仕事だから
いろんな工夫して教えるのは先生の仕事なんです
普通のネクタイ着いて教室に入ったら
子供たちが全然知らんふりしてるんだったら
歌舞伎の衣装でも借りてきて授業やればいいんです
そうすると なんだこれと驚いて
子供たちは授業を聞くかもしれない
ですから 工夫するのは教える側の仕事なんです
であるならば 昔から道徳を喋っている人々はそれなりの工夫していないと
社会を説得するために工夫していないと
工夫していないんだから
みんなも まあ人を殺さないこともいいし
でもまあその時何かあったら殺しちゃいますよということになっているでしょうに
そういうことで まあ世界の歴史っていうのは
簡単に血にまみれている歴史なんです
弱肉強食の歴史なんです
いかに他人に迷惑をかけない人々を殺したかという歴史ばっかりなんです
戦争っていうのはそういうものなんです
そこで今思い出したのは
このインドので現れた一番偉大なる王様がいて
アショーカと呼ぶんですけど
英字 僕は今覚えて覚えてないんですが
やっぱり回答は でアショーカという王様がいて
その王様がこのアレクサンダー王の影響でも徹底的にインドで戦争をやっちゃったんですね
やってやっても インドはもうほとんどもう自分の国にしてしまったんです
そこで南の方でカーリンガという南インドのものすごい大きな国がありまして
王様はアショーカ で 戦略した地方はカーリンガなんです
そちらで戦争をした  南の方もつかまなくちゃいけないんだ
戦略しなくちゃいけないんだ
その人々は徹底的に攻撃したんです
攻撃はしたんだけど 軍隊とかそういう能力はそんなになかったんです
とにかく 負けない 報復しない
それでこちらがいて 平気でもう家ごと子供をまとめてまとめて殺していく
何も抵抗もなく もう殺されて殺されていくと
でも 何 100万人も殺されて
まあそれ全部王様が書いておいているんです
碑文に石に彫って 私はこれぐらい殺しましたと
で その時はその王様が考え方変えちゃったんですね
自分が何やってるんですかと
何のためにこの武器も持ってない人々に
自分でプライドを持ってる人々
誰かの植民地に支配下になりたくないと思っている人々は平気で殺すんですか？と思って
それっきりやめますと引き上げたんです
それっきりで その王様がもう
他の生命に対しては手を上げなかったんです
それでなぜ偉大な王になったかというと
それからなんです それだけかもしれません
歴史の中でできた人のことを書いているのは
それで彼がいろいろ宗教を勉強して
で 心が変わえて こんなことをやっていけませんと
古い時代で動物にまで病院を作ったんです
王っていうのは人を守るものであって
殺すものじゃないんだと
守るんだったら生命まで守らなくちゃいけないんだと
それだったら動物にまで病院まで作ったりして
で 平気で自分をやったことを威張って書いているわけじゃないんです
私はこういう残酷なことをやりましたと
これぐらい人を殺したんだと
でも このアショーカという私がこれからは絶対戦争の法螺貝は吹きませんと
その代わりに法の真理の法螺貝を吹きますと
ダンマベーリという昔の言葉で法の太鼓を叩くんだと
そんなふうな人がいまだに現れてないでしょうに
とにかく自分の権力のために何でもするでしょうに
どんな汚いことでも 一人が現れて消えちゃった
自分の国の歴史の中でも
そういう立派な王様が何人か現れたんだけど
一人が厳密に道徳的に守ろうと思ったんです
もしかすると一番短い寿命なんです
その王様が 王になって
もしかすると7  8年もいなかったんです
誰とも戦わない お寺育ちなんです
お寺で育って大きくなって
父親が亡くなったら お坊さんたちに言われて帰ると
で 嫌々で国に戻って王になったんです
なったんだけど まあ徹底的に生命は誰一人も目もかけないで頑張っていると
そこでみんな王様はなんか軽く見て
あっちこっちで暴動を起こしたり
いろんなことをやって
その人全然もう何もしない
それで自分の弟かな まあ弟が暴動を起こしたら
まあいいですよと あなたが国が欲しければ
私は国のために一人の人とも戦わないんだと
私のために なんで私は軍隊に命令するんですか？と
行って戦えと 向こう側がもう戦争を売ってるんだと
だから戦略されているんだから
自分の国を守るのは当たり前でしょうということを言ってないんです
いえ その人がやりたければやってもいいと
で 私の仕事はあなた方を守ることだ
ですから 血一滴も流すようにしませんと
それは王の仕事やと言って
その場で帰っちゃったんです
全部捨てて で 短い寿命でしたけど
後で殺されたんです 王をやめて
森の中に入って修行を始めたんです
もう何もいりませんと
自分が本物の王なんです
自分の国民を守るんです
守るんだから 一滴でも
さっきはっきり書いてるんです
蚊が吸うぐらいの血 蚊吸うぐらいの血でも私のためには流せませんと
言って帰ったんだけど
そこでその人を調べて調べて調べて捕まって首を切っちゃったんです
で その首切った王様がもう 20年以上王っていたんです
だから歴史ってのはそんなもんなんです
道徳を守る人には立場がない
で あの まあ古い話にまた戻りますけど
一応道徳はしっかりと教えなかった
一応人間は理解しなかった
どっちにも先生が悪いということなんですね
しっかりと教えなかったならば
先生が悪い しっかりと理解できなかったならば
それもだいたい先生が悪い
社会にも原因があるかもしれませんだけど
どうしたっても勉強できない子は
まあ子供のせいも半分ありますけど
やっぱり先生は思い存分頑張らなくちゃいけない
それはもうどうしようもないことで
あるいは社会は随分いい加減で
好き勝手で都合によって行動したと
その 3つなんですね で
それに付け加えて言いたいのは
あの道徳やらああだこうだと言うんだけど
その先生方は何のために道徳を守るべきかということをわかってなかいなかったということを
いわゆる生命の幸福という概念
生命の幸福を覚えておいてください
その言葉は ウェルフェアオブオールリビングディーンスという英語で言うならば
すべての生命の幸福という概念は歴史の中でなかなか見えないんです
じゃあ皆様は随分なじみがありますから
聖書を読んでみてください
出てきますかね その言葉が
生命のこう ヴェーダ聖典は読めないでしょうね
まあ日本訳もそれなりに適当にいろいろありますけど
アヴェスタとかも日本訳はあるみたいしね
英訳はありますから イスラム教のもう何でしたっけ
イスラム教の聖書は何といいますか
コーラン アルコーラン
ホーリーコーラン 読んでみてください
生命の幸福という概念が出てくるかと
出てこないんです 後時代
後の時代のヒンドゥーの世界ではいくらか生まれたんだけど
この言葉自体 仏教以外ないんですね
ですから 俺道徳論は成り立たないんです
自分の都合を語ってるだけなんです
だから言えるのは 世の中で道徳論っていうのは結局はなかったんですということなんです
今更子供たち聞いたっても
別に面白くも何にもないんで
そんなこと昔もなかったんです
なぜ人殺すといけないということに答えが
それにびっくりする先生も
もうまあ先生はびっくりするな
でもそこまで先生はそんなこと勉強してないんだから
どうしてほしいかとびっくりするのは普通なんですけど
まあ普通のことなんです
そこで現代人になると
現代人の頭は昔と違って
昔はもう科学もなかったし
で それなりに信仰中心に勉強しましたから
なんでも薬にしたっても
もう星占いやらそんな知識でしょうね
昔あったのは たとえ農業にしたっても
その中でいろんな信仰が入っていたんだから
畑の神様がいて もう神様の機嫌を取って種をまくとか
そこで豊作農作物できたところで神様に感謝する儀式
儀礼 祭りやるとか そういう風にこのあの信仰と一緒になって
昔の人々は生きてきたんです
信仰には理屈はないんです
この山に神様がいると言っちゃったら
昔の人々じゃお供えしましょうとというぐらいで終わっちゃったんです
今の人だったらどこにいるんですかね
とこ探すんで 写真でも撮ってやろうかと
昔の人々にはあの辺に行ったらお化けが出るぞと言ったら
やっぱりそこには行かない方がいいんだよと怖がっちゃうんです
今の子供たちと言ったら
あ そう じゃあみんなで行って写真撮ってやろうと
お化けの幽霊の写真とか
ですから そこら辺 昔と今の違うところなんですね
昔はほとんど信仰と一緒にもうごちゃ混ぜ生き方は
だからなぜという質問はしないんです
あ そうですかと それで終わっちゃうんです
この山は神様です あ そうですか
ありがとうございますと
それだけで終わっちゃったんです
ですから 現代人というのは
ちゃんとした理屈と科学と
まあ合理的な考え方とか
いるならば写真に写るはずだよと思う人々なんです
ですから 現代人は道徳は理解しないということは
古い人々は理解したんですか？と聞くと
私は全くなかったと言いたいんです
古い人々もものすごいインチキ
大嘘つき やってない で
例なんかいくらでも出せます
隣の人 隣の人を愛しなさいとおっしゃった教えを持って
十字架を持ってどれぐらい人を殺されたんですかね
なんであんなことできるんですかね
ローマの法王さえ戦争に出たんだから
平和の宗教だと言ってるイスラム教のトルコ人とかね
徹底的に戦略してあちこち人を殺していったでしょ
インドまで来て なんであんなことできるんですかね
自分の国は 1505年でポルトガル人が入っちゃったんだけど
入って国を捕まることできませんでしたけど
まあ海の方 いくらいくつかの場所を取っちゃって
そこら辺の子供たちまで平気で殺しちゃったんです
それで殺した人の記録がありまして
ポルトガルから後で研究する歴史研究する人々はそれを解読して発表したんだけど
そこにこう書いてるんですね
神様信じさせるために
おっぱいを飲んでる子供たちを引っ張って
上に空の上に出して 鉄砲の上にベイというなんか刀みたいな
そこで取っちゃうんだと
取って殺しちゃうんだと
そういうふうに我々偉大なる神の教え
この野蛮人のところでみんな広げたんだと
それでカトリック教は広げたんだけど
そこら辺で あんなもんで宗教伝道だと言えるんですかね
それで次にその連中帰ったところで
オランダ人が入ってきて
また違う宗教を教えて
またそれからイギリス人が入ってきて
やりたい放題 で またそこでそういう偉大なる教えがあるんですよと
そんなものは信じる人も大馬鹿者で
偉大なる聖なる教えだったら行動で表してほしいんですね
今もそういう汚いことをずっとやってるんです
で 言うとこちらの気持ちまで悪くなるんだから
あまり言いたくないと
情報っていうのはいくらでも持ってるんです
ですから この 昔のという人々も結局ろくでもない人間なんです
じゃあ今はどうですかと
国民のためにと喋る人々あれ
国民のため 結局自分のためなんでしょうに
嘘ばっかりでしょう どんな国でも同じことなんです
我々知ってる立派な人やとか
有名な人とかね 素晴らしい政治家とか
ああだこうだという人々っていうのはみんなそうでしょうに
ですから 現代人 子供たちがそれを聞いているんです
アメリカに イラクに片っ端から爆弾を落とす権利はあるんだけど
それは素晴らしい行為であって
大量殺人は正しい でもあなたは人殺すなと
あれ 何の理屈ですかね
そんなことは大人は頭悪いんだから信じますけど
お金も出しますけど じゃあ殺してくださいと
子供にはちょっと信じがたいんです
1万人殺すのはヒーローであって
一人殺すのは殺人であると
これはこのインドである回たい映画があって
インドでそれ上映禁止したんだけど
スリランカではものすごくそれをもうもうビデオまで売ってるんです
このある女の人のストーリーで
大変低いカーストの女の人が
上のカーストの人々にいじめられたりして
まあいろんな大変なひどい目に遭ったりして
まあ何といいますか レイプまでされたされたりして
そこで何もないんだから
父親がその子を売っちゃうんですね
金持ちじゃなくて カーストの上のうちに上のカーストの人のうちに売られるんだけど
これ小さな女の子なんです
結婚させちゃうんです
結婚相手がごく普通の大人なんです
その人から見れば お父さんともっと年上ぐらいか
もうほぼそんなもので
そういう子供を責めちゃうんだ
あの人から見れば 自分結婚した大御所さんだから
その子はまだ大きくなってないんです
まだ小さな女の子なんです
そういうストーリーなんですけど
一応実際にインドでそういうこと起こるんです
そこで彼女 ちっちゃな時
そんなことをされちゃって
そこでものすごい声で泣くんだけど
男のお母さんが自分の部屋のドアを閉じて
何のこともしないで黙ってるんです
その場合もやっぱり女だからわかるでしょうに
小さな女の子っていうのはもう責めてはいけないと
で 守ってくれない それでそういうことで大きくなった女の子が
ものどうでもある なんて言いますか
もうグループに入っちゃって
この過激派みたいなグループに入って
みんな責めるんです で
すっごい恐ろしくて で
その悪いことをやっているグループは
最初は彼女を入れてこなかった
女だからダメですよと
でも彼女は強引に入って
もう暴力を振るうようになってしまったところで
あまりにも恐ろしいんだから
結局リーダーになってしまっちゃうんです
で そこで彼女に誰かが一言葉言うんですね
とにかく彼女を初めて殺す人は自分の旦那なんです
で すっごいきつい場面なんですけど
まあもう殺しただけじゃなくて
殴って殴ってとか まあ見られないようにすごくできてるんで
その映画っていうのは
で それで気に入ってる男がいるんです
そのグループの中で その男はこの彼女の精神的な状態を知ってるんだから何もしない
それであんまりにも痛いまでやってるんだから
もういいでしょうと言って引っ張って持っていっちゃうんです
それからリーダーになって
もう大量に人を殺しちゃいますけど
で そこで彼女にこう言うんです
あなたは一人二人殺したら殺人ですと
でも人人殺しちゃったらヒーローですよと
で 全くその通りで もうあの地方でも何もコントロールできなくて
この このカーストの上の人々やら人を責める人々やら
みんな殺していっちゃうんです
で そこで政府が手を挙げて契約書を書いて
彼女に契約書を書いてやめましょうと
武器を返しましょうと言ったら
彼女は自分のカーストには学校を作ってくれと
みんな守ってくれと ああだこうだとか言って
全部武器を渡す場面で映画終わっちゃいますけど
インドでなんでそれ禁じられたんですかというと
やっぱり人殺すやら暴動することやら
まあ正当化しているんだから良くないということで
ですからまあ その点で見るとあまりいい映画じゃないんだけど
まあ最後に彼女はやっぱり自分のことを願ってないんだから
この差別されている人々のことを考えちゃったんだから
そこら辺でなんとか道徳的にまとめているんです
そこで私の頭に残った言葉はたった一つ
一人殺したら殺人で 人ぐらい殺したら
なんとかの反対運動をやっているリーダーで殺人じゃないんですね
そんな考え方は世の中で確実にあることだから
世の中で大量殺人する人々はみんなある運動をやっている人々
運動をやっているなんとかのリーダーなんですね
殺人だと認めないんです
ただお金欲しくてご飯食べられない
食べるご飯はない お金もない
それで人を殺しちゃって
お金を奪っちゃったら
もうとんでもない恐ろしい殺人者になっちゃうんです
なんだそれはと それは世の中の法律でしょうにね
ですから やっぱりこの道徳っていうのは
そういうとんでもない違う世界次元で考えた方がいいと私は思っているんです
で 現代人が聞いているのは
道徳って何ですか？ということ
そこで今から我々ははっきり道徳を教えていない
そこではっきり教えてないと言ったっても
ちょっと皆さんにまだ例を出してないんだからわからないんですね
で 私たちにどういうふうに教えてくれたんですか？そんな悪いことをしちゃったら
罰が当たるんだと 地獄に落ちるんだと
いいことをしたら天国に行くんだと
嘘を言ったらどうなるんですか？舌を抜かれるんだと
閻魔さん あれは我々古い人間だからね
バカもんでしたから信じたんだけど
今の子たちはそんなことを信じるんですかね
お化けがいるんだと言ったら
もう写真撮ろうとする連中だから
嘘を言ったら歯を抜かれますよと学校で言ってみてください
学校の道徳教育授業で
君たちは嘘言ってはいけません
なぜならば 閻魔さんでしたっけ？閻魔さんが歯を抜くんだと
真実を言ったら天国に行くんだと
だからちゃんと真実を喋りなさいと言ってみてください
正真正銘のインチキ嘘の教えでしょうに
それだったら何も証拠を出してないでしょうに
で なぜ私は聖書も道徳を言ってないと言うというと
君らは私が作ったんだと
だからこういうこういうことをするなかれと
私は偉大なる神はアブラハムでしたっけ？こういうモーセね
モーセにまあ十戒をまあこれから言いますと
守らなかったらもう大変ひどい目に遭いますと
永遠の地獄にそこにそこでもう永遠に焼けますと
言うと 一番道徳を犯しているのは誰ですかね
神でしょうに その人に道徳を犯す権利があって
人間が道徳を犯してはいけないと
そんなことで道徳成り立たないんです
人間創ったのはあなたですから
あなたの責任でしょうと
もし私たちのやり方間違っているならば
それはあなたが悪いでしょうと
あなたに人を地獄に落として
永遠の火で焼ける 焼き
焼いて苦しまれる権利あるんだけど
なんで我々に人を殺す権利ないんですか？と
あれ冗談じゃないんです
あれこそ道徳を犯しているこんなんです
だから歴史的な事実を見ると
確実にそういう人々は道徳を犯しているんです
確実に 数えられないほど人を殺してきたんです
はっきり言ってないんです
なぜ悪いから 神様に なんて言いますか
背く人はいけないと そんなことになりたたないんです
それだったら背かないように作るのが彼の責任でしょうに
サタンの誘惑に 何でしたっけ？負けるなと
サタン作ったその人の責任でしょうに
私たちは人間にはどうしようもないんだから
作られたものばっかりだけだから
設定されているシステムの中で生きていられるだけですから
だから綺麗な女の人だったら
やっぱりどうしようもないんです
もう心の中 体の中 暖かくなっちゃうんです
いくら結婚していていても
なんか他の美人が見ちゃったら
もうそこら辺にちょっと目がいっちゃうんです
それはサタンのサタンの誘惑というならば
サタンこそ悪いんでしょうし
その人を許してる人が悪いでしょうし
だから道徳の象徴的なおかしやが道徳を守れと言うんだから
これはもうヤクザが暴力振るうなと言うことと同じでしょうに
だからそういうふうな
これ 僕はキリスト教だけ言ったんだからといって
別にキリスト教だけ悪いわけじゃないんです
特別に恨みがあっているわけでもないんです
ただ そんな世の中の宗教っていうのは
そういうふうにも曖昧な
まあしっかりと喋ってない
お釈迦様いうのは宗教家に悪口言ってないんです
みんな一生懸命喋ろうとしているんです
いいこと でもお釈迦様がいつでも言うのはわかってないんだから完全ではないんだと言ってることはもうガタガタですよと
編み物と同じなんですねと
我々セーターとかなんとか編んだっても
最後のノット作って結びを結んでしっかりしなきゃ
それずっとずれちゃうんです
この編み物を 道徳という編み物を編んだんだけど
途中でやめてるんだから
この糸を引いたら全部抜けるんです
そういうことになってるんです
ですから 我々現代人にとっては
罰が当たる 天国に行く
地獄に落ちる そういうものは何の意味もないんです
そんな脅しでと言っても
じゃあ他の人々に罰が当たるんですかと
例えば人を殺したら罰が当たるんだと
まあ一人を殺したら罰が当たるのはわかりますけど
300人  400人殺した人になんで罰が当たらないんですかと
万引きしちゃったらすぐ罰が当たりますけど
5億円くらい盗んじゃったらほとんど罰が当たらないと
そういう社会でしょ 我々生きてるの
だから誰が信じるんですか？罰が当たると言ったって
そんなことを信じるんだったら
その子供たちはもう情けないんです
だから信じないでとことんチャレンジする
あの心というのは 僕は素晴らしいと
なんか将来見込みがあるんだと
わずかな光でもあるんだと思っちゃいます
とにかく 現代の子供たちに
この大人たちがすーっと作り上げてきた
この社会の欠陥がバレてるんです
我々はずっとなんかもうなんとかガタガタ状態で社会作ってきたんだけど
もうみんな守る まあ人に優しくしましょうと言いながら
人に優しくないし 人を殺してはいけないと言いながらも殺したりやったりして
まああちこちでごまかしてごまかしてきた
今まで 1998年まで
遠い 4000年前のもっと前の古い文明から人間を作ってきた
この巨大な人間の歴史の中である
この欠陥は今の子供たちにバレてるんです
わかってるんです そういうことだと僕は思ってるんです
で 我々古い人間っていうのは
言われる通りにする 自分やっていることは全然顧みることはしない
言われる通りにする で
規則は守る 守るべきですから
守りますよと みんなやってるんだから
みんなに従いましょうとかね
まあ誰でもやってることだからやりますと
そういう今までの人間っていうのは
聞いたレールで走るだけなんですね
私たちもまあみんな人を殺してないんだから
私も人を殺しませんと
みんな堂々と嘘を言わないで隠れて嘘を言うんだから
私も堂々と嘘を言わないことやめますと
みんなあまり人のものを取ってないんだけど
私もやりませんと それぐらいの道徳なんです
社会に今までやったのは
ですから もう考えることはしない
顧みることはしない なぜ悪いかと
そこの辺に世の中で今まで哲学者も宗教もいろんな人々も作っている道徳にね
すごい大きな欠陥があるんです
で 今の人々 子供たちが社会に入ろうとするとどうなるかというと
もう教育システムはきちんとできているし
社会システムきちんとできるし
で 子供たちにもまあ言われる通りにやればいいんです
学校に行って決まってる科目勉強すればいいんです
決まってる規則を守ればいいんです
全部もう死ぬまで全部プログラム書いてるんです
だから今生まれて現代生まれてくる子供たちはある面でかわいそうなんです
全部死ぬまで もうとっくに大人たちが全部もうレールを引いて決まってるんです
そこでまずいことに 科学的な合理的な教育受けちゃうんです
それで子供たちにとっては自分で考えなくてもいいことになってるんです
ですから 子供たちはこのもう学校に行ったっても
全部考えてくれてるんだから
質問試験に行ったっても
全部答えそこにあるんだから選べばいいんです
1か2か3か5かと ですから
子供たちにはもう頭に仕事がないんです
ですから 人間の頭が妄想してるんです
この妄想っていうのは
この まあただ走り回るという意味で
で 人間の思考能力は妄想してるんです
そう 妄想って書いてくれる
妄想 想像の想像  じゃなくて
この想定です  すみません
理解だから  別に子供たちが我々一般的に言う妄想してるわけじゃないんです
考え方 まあ余計なことに単なる走ってるんです
ですから 私に言いたいのは
この人殺してはいけないということは簡単な質問ではなくて
もうこれから 21 世紀になるんだから
もうすべて科学も新しくなったならば
我々の治療法も何でもまるっきり新しい時代になったならば
情報の社会が生まれたならば
もう誰でも自由になって
もういろんなもうどんな人ともコンタクトを取れる世界になったならば
この古臭くてガタガタでどうにもならない
でも人間に必要な道徳というものは
根本ところから全部考え直して
しっかりした論理的な
合理的な 科学的な道徳システムを作らなくちゃいけないと
で そこまで一部なんですけど
もうちょっとずっと喋りっぱなしで皆様疲れますので
まあちょっと 10分 15
分休憩いたします では
よろしくお願いします
これから第2部始まります
で 今まで私はこのずっと人類の中でしっかりした道徳っていうのは論理的にしっかりと成り立ってないということを言ってきたんですが
まあといっても 道徳というものは成り立ってなくても
成立していなくても まああったことはあったんですね
で これから我々に新しい道徳観が作られるかというと
別に新しく作るものはその中でもないんです
ただ あの ちゃんとした論理的にできてない
ですから 論理的な人間にとってはなかなか納得いかないという問題なんですね
で まあ新しい道徳といえば
まあそれも例えばね 情報がどんどん発達していっちゃうと
人の情報を取ってはいけないとかね
犯してはいけない 例えばコンピューター犯罪とかね
新しいものが出てきちゃうし
で まあそういうのはもう新しく出てきてくる道徳的な問題なんですけど
例えば自分に通信で他人のコンピューターにつなげることできると
できるでいっても それは良くない
許可ないと それも別に新しい道徳にならないんですね
人間が人の家に勝手に入ってはいけないんだから
それと同じことなんです
それからこのハッカーとかね
まあプログラムを壊すと
もう最近なんか日本でもなんか銀行かどっちでしたっけ？まあ
あ  NTT かどちらかのまあプログラム
むちゃくちゃ誰かに壊されたと
で そうすると新しい法律作ったりするんだけど
道徳論から見れば それは人の財産を壊すことなんです
ですから 昔からもうそれはまあ泥棒に入ってるんです
ただ お金でなくても その人のすごい財産だから
例えば私が持っているプログラムやら
私のデータを誰かが通信でコンピューターにコンタクト
それも壊しちゃったら
私の財産を壊したことだから泥棒なんですね
ですから 現代 新しく現れる現れてくる罪に使っても
古い道徳で何のことなく説明できるんです
ですから 私たちに新しく新しい戒律やら規則やらね
まあはっきり言うと作る必要はない
それぐらいできてることはできてるんです
でもなんか問題があるんです
問題があるんだから 道徳があったんだけど
ほとんど人々が守らなかったっていうのは事実なんです
歴史上事実なんです それは否定してほしくない
弱いものはずっといじめられてきたんです
ないものの人からあるものを全部奪われたんです
力あるもの 人だけ 元気で生きるだけじゃなくて
歴史まで作っちゃうんです
一緒に自分の名前を放っておいて置いちゃうんです
それは本当の歴史です
そこを否定してほしくない
すべて事実を見てほしい
それだけ それで あの話の途中でご質問があったんだけど
このあの道徳はないと言ったんだけど
あるんじゃないかと質問がありましたけど
皆様聞いてないんですけど
で まあそれはそういうことで
別に道徳はあったんだけど
しっかりしていないガタガタ状態で
そこで例に出たのは あのイエス様もね
ほっぺたに殴ったら 次の右ほっぺたを殴ったら左も向けなさいと
それは道徳ではないかと
で 問題はわかりますかね
人があなたの右ほっぺたにぶん殴ったら
その人に左ほっぺたも当てなさいとか
あれ何言ってるんですかね
あれでわかりますかね
だから殴り返すなというぐらいは強引になるほど殴り返すとあかんかと
はわかりますけど でもなんで殴り返しちゃいけないんですかね
ほっぺた殴っちゃったんだから
ぶん殴った方がいいのに
だから言いたければしっかり言いなさいというのは
私は先生に言いたいんですね
イエスという先生に あんた言ってることは間違ってないんだけど
言い方が間違ってるんだと
言い方が間違っちゃうと効果がない
だからここでなくしてる部分があるんです
なくしてる部分がこういうことなんですね
あいつは私の右ほっぺたを殴ったと
その人は怒ってるんだと
私に対して で それで良くないんだと
互いに怒り合って だからどうぞこちらも殴ってくださいと
こっちを殴って はい どうぞこちらもやってくださいと
そうすると その人の怒りがその瞬間に消えちゃう
あ なんでこのこいつを殴るんですか？ともういいやつではないかと
すぐ心にその人に対する愛情が生まれちゃうんです
それでも問題は万事解決なんです
その瞬間から敵同士じゃなくてもう仲良しになっちゃうんです
その部分 大事なところ言わないで
右に殴ったら左も与えと
そればっかり言っちゃったら
もうもう下手のいいところなんです
人に話すと 人と話すんだったら
しっかりと もう納得いくように言ってもらいたいんですね
だから私が同じ文章を取ってこう言うんです
あなたの右ほっぺたにその人を殴ったのは
あなたに対して怒ってるんだと
理由はどうであろうか
その人を怒っていることだけ事実ですと
彼が正しいか あなたが正しいかということは今問題ないんだと
結果として怒っているんだと
ですから 怒りさえ収めればお互いに仲良くなるんだから
じゃあ右ほっぺたに殴ってもらいなさい
そうすると相手の怒りが消えちゃう
消えて ああ まあこの人に殴って悪かったと
いい人やという気持ちが生まれてきて
お互いに仲良くなるんです
そこはなくて ジーザスは神様であって
神の子であって だから言うことを信じなさいという背景の中にあるんだから
誰も信じてないんです
私は信じないのは当たり前なんですけど
キリスト教の人も信じてないんです
一番信じて 僕は信じてます
あれは教えは正しいんだと
でもキリスト教の人は信じてないんです
残念ですけど 悔しいですけど
だから まあちょっと悪いことしたらやり返そうと思ってるのは
我々アジア人ですか？ヨーロッパ人ですか
そちらでしょう そちらはキリスト教
キリスト教文化だから
最近またまたイラクに爆弾落とそうと脅したの誰ですか？仏教の人
ですから まあ信じてないんです
その人々さえ だから私に悪口を言う権利はもう一寸法あります
どうせ元々キリスト教じゃないんだから
ということで まあそんなまあまあ悪口を言ってもいいんだけど
まあそれから 第2部にどのように道徳というものは成り立たせますかという
まあお釈迦様のお話に
まあこちら仏教を喋る場だから
まあ仏教の世界に入ります
で お釈迦様っていうのは
まず道徳を喋る前に 汝
自分で考えようと と立場で教えるんです
それだけでもすごい立場が違うんです
汝 君は自分で考えてみましょう
と それ有名な文句なんですね
お釈迦様の文句の中で
その態度は他のどこにも見当たらないんです
自分たちで自由に考えましょうと言って
ずっと道徳を喋ってるんです
ですから そこで言うのは
私がブッダだからと信じる必要ないんだと
これは古い話だから 別にどうってことない
そんなことは私はブッダであろうか
悟っていようかと 古い話であろうか
歴史だったんだから そんなどうってことないんだから
だから僕は今まで言ったことは
んでもない もう何言ってるんです？皆さんも驚くかもしれませんだけど
これは正真正銘のお釈迦様の立場なんです
文明では素晴らしい教えがあったんだから
だから何ですかと どうったことない
自分で考えろ 昔の人々もう死んじゃったんだから
今の人々 我々今生きてるんだから
我々は我々で考える ですから
歴史にあったんだからといって
伝統にあるんだからといって
文明 文明の中で 文化の中でずっと信じてくるんだからといって
偉大なるお釈迦様に 偉大なるもうイエス様に教えてくれたんだからといって信じるなかれと
自分で考えろと で そういうことでお釈迦様は道徳を喋るんです
ですから 自分で考えて自分で納得いったならば
そこで文句ないでしょうに
ということは これは悪い
これは正しいということを言いたければ
その言われる人が いわゆるどうせ大人が年下に言うんだから
道徳っていうのは 我々子供が道徳を教えてくれたら生意気だと言うんだけどね
それもよくないんです
私は年下であろうか 上であろうが
それ関係なく何か教えたことを真剣に考えますけど
でも人間の社会はそうじゃないんだよ
もう年下の人が何かこれは良くないんではなく
言ったら生意気だと言っちゃいますし
それも大人が道徳ないんだからなんです
真実は子供が言おうが大人が言おうが
もう誰が言おうが関係ないんです
真実は真実だから ですからまあ
その場合でも大人の側に問題があるんです
結構子供というのはしっかりことを言うんです
ものすごい驚くほどの道徳的なことをとか
そうすると生意気と それも我々忘れてやってはいけないことなんです
間違っていることを言うのは
あんた言ってること間違ってるよと言った方がそれは別なんですけど
まあですから 仏教では汝自分で考えよという立場で教えるんです
ですから お釈迦様にお釈迦様が道徳を語る時は
罰が当たる 地獄に落ちる
ブッダに逆らうなと そういう脅しはありえないんです
ですから 罰が当たるならば当たる
地獄に落ちるならば落ちると
天国に行くならば行ける
それはもう脅しで使ってないんです
まず自分で考えて納得して
すればいいと そこでその経典にちょっと中に入ってみますけど
で こう言うんです お釈迦様
じゃあ人がものすごい欲で吉で
心が欲に汚れているんだと
汚染されているんだと
で 欲ばっかししかない心っていうのは
あなた方は素晴らしいと思いますか？と
それちょっとかっこ悪いんだと
聞く人々は言うんです
自分で考えればいいんだから
自分の心だから 自分の心
自分のこと 欲しかないと
それはちょっとかっこ悪いでしょうし
それはちょっとかっこ悪いんだと
そうすると そういう汚れた心で人が喋ったりする
行動したりする その汚れた人のことを心で考えたりする
そういうものは正しいかと
あるいは正しくないかとあなた方は思いますか？と
で そう思いません それは間違っていると
それお釈迦様道徳 だから私が言います
欲に汚れた心で喋るな
行動するな 考えるなと
それはあなた方自分で今言ってるんだと
だから相手がちゃんとわかってるってことでしょうし
だから だから私は私が言ったんだからと信じる必要はないんだと
で 逆にもこうも聞くんです
例えば怒りがないと 汚れた心がないと
人に窃盗することやら
盗むことやら この虐殺やら
そういうものできますかと
できないと だから汚れた心はよくないと
ずっとそういうふうに対話的に相手を納得させて
納得させて ちゃんと証明があって
証拠があって 道徳を喋るべきなんです
そこで宗教的な道徳を言うと
例えば天国にあるならば
天国があるならば 天国に行けるという人は汚れた人が行くんですか？清らかな人が行くんですかと
どう思いますかと 天国はありますよではなくて
もしたとえに天国みたいな素晴らしいところがあるとするならば
そちらに行く連中はどっちですかと
どんな人？それだったらやっぱり心清らかな人が行くんだと
もし地獄あるならばどちらが行くんですかと
ですから お釈迦様はそれで終わり
道徳は 天国をもって地獄をもって人を脅したり
誘惑したりする必要はないんです
あってもなくても構いません
神が人間を作っても作らなくてもどうでもいいんです
道徳は成り立つんです
神がいなきゃキリスト教の道徳成り立たない
アッラーはアッラーという神がいなきゃイスラム教の道徳は成り立たない
なんだ あんなガタガタの道徳
天国なければ成り立たない
あの道徳にならないんです
言い方まずい 仏教では天国あってもなくても道徳成り立ちます
地獄があってもなくても道徳は成り立ちます
輪廻があってもなくても道徳は成り立ちます
それが仏教の立場なんです
そういう風にこの本人が納得して
あ これは悪いと これは正しいと
聞く人が納得すると 道徳っていうのは自然に守られるんです
なんで人々が道徳を犯すかというと
納得していないんです
やってもいいやと思っちゃうんです
納得しているんだったらやらないんです
だから道徳を語る人々の責任なんです
私は毒を持ってきて また饅頭も持ってきて
これは饅頭で これは毒ですけど
あんたこの毒食べてみたらどうですかと
ただ食べますかね 本当は食べたいんだけど
やっぱり道徳だから私は饅頭を食べますという
嫌で嫌で饅頭を食べるアホがいるんですかね
これは毒入ってるんだと
例えば饅頭 2つ僕は持ってきて
どうぞ召し上がってくださいって
一つにべろで舐めて置いておくんだと
もう一つはすごい丁寧に置いておくんだと
その人は食べる場合は
ほとんど食べないと思います
2つ もし食べるとしたならば
どっちが食べるんですかね
舐めたところ 舐めた饅頭
そこでその人は本当は舐めた饅頭食べたいんだけど
まあもうやっぱりもう悪いことしてはいけないんだから
まあ嫌で まあこれ食べる
そんなことないでしょうに
食べる場合は何のことなく
自然に なんだこれ食うもんかと
人に出すんだったらもっと丁寧に出せと怒るまでして
綺麗な饅頭を食べるでしょうに
そういう立場がなきゃ
道徳っていうのは世界で成り立たないんです
ですから 悪いものはしっかりとこういうことで悪いと説得させなくちゃいけないんです
そうしなかった昔の人々は間違っていたんです
もう簡単に言います それから次のポイントっていうのは
道徳には制限あってはならない
いわゆる普遍性 英語ではユニバーサルティ
道徳というものには普遍性がなければなりません
普遍性といえば 時間と距離というのは関係ないものでなければいけません
わかりやすくします 日本で悪いものは外国でも悪いと
外国で悪いものは日本でも悪いし
1945年で悪いものは2000年でも悪いはずなんです
そうでないとそれは道徳じゃないんです
もし人々が紀元前 3000年で悪いと決めたものは
今 21世紀でも悪いでなければ道徳ではないんです
インドでやってはいけないこと
日本でやってもいいということになったら
そんなものは道徳にならないんです
ですから 道徳を語る場合は
こんな並の人間には語れない
まずすごい人ができていないと語れない
だからイエス様やらお釈迦様やら
そういう まあソクラテスやら
そういうすごい人々しか喋ってないんです
まあ現代でもまあそれなりにまあ倫理学者っていうのは結構天才みたいな人々ですけど
もう並の人間でなぜ喋れないものなんです
とにかく普遍性は一番必要なんです
普遍性あると誰にも逆らえないんです
でも人間作る道徳って何ですかね
この場合は殺してもいいと
この場合は殺してはいけないとか
そうすると条件になるんだから
やる人々にもそれなりに条件いろいろごまかせるんです
言い訳作るんです どうしようもなく
まあこういうこういうことでやりましたよと
ですから あの人間が間違ってるっていうのは
例えば第二次世界大戦を考えちゃうと
まあ戦争に行って入って
軍隊に入った人を殺すことこそ素晴らしいと
戦争終わっちゃったら
平和こそ素晴らしい いい加減にしなさいと
どっちですかね 正しいのは
もし今のこと正しければ
昔の人々はとんでもないことをやったことになっちゃうし
昔の人々はいいことをやったならば
今我々は平和でとんでもない連中なんです
我々の戦争たちが もうお父さん
おじいさんの時代で一生懸命人を殺していたのに
なんで我々やらないかといえば
我々はもうできてできた息子でなくなっちゃうんです
だから そういうふうに
この時代に応じて変わるものっていうのは恐ろしいんです
そういうことは道徳でないと綺麗に区別する能力が必要なんです
ちょっと難しいポイントなんですけど
世の中の人々 我々にこうしなさい
こうしてはいけないと言っても
すぐ鵜呑みにするのではなくて
こういうことをアメリカでやってもいけないかと
アフリカでやってもいけないかと
あるいは紀元 2500年でやってもいけないかと
この例えば昔の人はやってもいけないことを我々は考えなくちゃいけないんです
やっぱりいつでもやってはいけないことだったら
それは普遍性ある道徳なんです
ですから 道徳倫理っていうのは
もう時空関係超えているものでなければいけません
そういうことは 例えば生命っていうのは
人間っていうのは どんな生命でも呼吸しているんですね
呼吸っていうのは 酸素を酸素を吸って
二酸化炭素酸素を出すと
それが呼吸というわけです
そこで 生命によって我々は肺でやっているし
もう魚はエラでやっているし
で まあ他の動物もそれなりに自分のやり方でまあ呼吸をやっているんです
でも生命はもう呼吸をしなくちゃいけないっていうことは
もうどんな生命にも普遍的な事実なんですね
それぐらいのしっかりしたことでないと
人間は守れないんです
道徳は 人間だから これは当たり前だと
それぐらいもうきちんと徹底的に
しっかりと道徳の世界は言わなくちゃいけない
そういう風に喋らなくちゃいけないし
大体仏教では大体そんな感じでは言ってるんです
そこで  あ 正しく道徳論を語る場合は
そういう風に まあ生命は呼吸しているんだと
呼吸というのは体に酸素を入れて二酸化炭素を出すことです
アメーバはアメーバなりにやっている
ミミズはミミズなりにそれをやっている
鳥はそれである方法でやっている
魚はそれなりの方法でやっている
植物は自分なりの方法でやっている
人間はそれでこのやり方
でもやり方はみんな同じですと
なぜならば 基本的にみんな生命ですから
呼吸している そこで道徳も全く同じで
それなりにやらなくちゃいけないと
それなりではなくて 確実にというふうに教えなくちゃいけない
そういうことで 皆様よくもう知っていると思いますけど
仏教のお釈迦様の経典を見てください
97%ぐらい出てくるのは何ですか？道徳ですか？倫理学
心理学ですか ほとんどあるのは心理学なんです
心の分析なんです 生命には体があって心があるんだと
体はこういうこういうふうに働くんです
物体は 心はこういうこういうふうに働くんだと
体と心の関係はこういう関係だと
そこは犬でも同じ 鳥でも同じ
魚でもみんな同じだと
心と体の関係は それで心が汚れちゃうと
どんどん体も悪くなっていっちゃうんだと
心は清らかになっちゃうと
どんどん体も良くなっていっちゃうんだと
ですから いろんなことで心が病んでいるんだと
病気だと その体の病気は捨てるのはいいことであるならば
心は病気ですから 心も病気だから治さなくちゃいけないんだと
そういうふうに言ってるんです
あなた方は体の体が病気な時
体が汚れた時 汚れた時
一生懸命薬を飲んだり
鏡を見て治したりするんじゃないんですかと
だから心も同じく汚れています
病気なんです 心もちゃんと治してくださいと
いうのはお釈迦様の教えで
何の根拠もなしに 理屈もなしに殺すなかれとか
そんなことは言わないんです
そうじゃなくて そうやってこう言うんです
例えば 人が汚れ 心はすごく怒りで汚れていると
他人に見たらすごく怒ったんだと
その時は喋る言葉も悪口でしょうと
傷つく言葉でしょうと
その言葉によって相手はまたさらに傷つくでしょうと
傷ついた相手がまたあなたにやり返しするでしょう
そうするとさらにあなたの心が汚れるでしょうと
そうすると この循環で終わりがないんだと
だから もともとあなたの心は病気だから
怒りで悩んでいるんで病んでるんだから
そこはなんとかいろいろ工夫ありますから
方法ありますから それを直せと
逆に言えば怒らないで相手殺されますかと
だから殺すなではなくて怒るなと
だから猫を見たら子猫を見たらものすごい可愛いんだと
ぬいぐるみみたいに あまりにも可愛いんだから殺してやるぞと首をひねられますかね
ですから そういうふうに科学的にきちんと教えるべきですけど
そう教えてないでしょうに
他の世界では お釈迦様の教えも全部あるのは心理学なんです
心の分析 それは全部科学的に
きちんと合理的に お釈迦様がおっしゃったことはこれ間違ってると言っちゃったら
まあ僕はこの場で仏教やめるんです
それぐらいきちんとしっかりと言ってるんです
だから科学なんです だから我々の現代
まあ宗教教えという場では言ってませんだけど
道徳的なことを学校でも教えるときは
この心の働きを教えてほしいんです
子供たちに体のことを教える授業あるでしょうに
なんで心の働きを教える授業ないんですか？心はどのようにできているんですか？どういうどういうものがあるんですかと
どんな時どんな反応するんですかと
そんな反応したらどうなるんですかとか
宗教嫌だったら 医学的にでも怒った人はどういうどんなホルモン体が流れるんですか？と
すごく怒ったらどれぐらい胃酸が出るんですか？と
脳はどんな反応をするか
もう知ってるんだから
情報いくらでもあるんだから
怒りは良くないと もうもう無意味な欲が良くないんだと
悩んではいけないんだと
暗い思考は良くないんだと
それは体にも悪いし 自分の行動
能力 全部鈍くなるんだと
もう仏教でなくても 今世の中で科学的にそういういくらでも情報はあるでしょうに
ですから お釈迦様はそういう昔
それはきちんと丁寧に完璧に教えておいてあるんです
だから まあヨーロッパやら日本やら
そういう心理学が発展していないというならば
まあ仏教では宗教という色がなくて
正真正銘の科学的な心理学があるんだから
勉強してみれば そんな問題はまるっきりなぜナセヒソ殺してはいけないかというのは出てこないんです
ですから その子供は そのナサヒソ殺してはいけないというその子供がどうやって人間
赤ちゃんが生まれるかと聞くんですかね
聞かないでしょうに ということは
そこら辺はちゃんと教えてるんだから知ってるんです
心の働きも教えていたならば
その子は絶対そんなことはしないんです
例えば万引きするなではなくて
万引きするときはあなたの気持ちはどうですかと
それははっきりその人に体験させてみれば
その時は暗くて嫌で 怒りでどうしようもない状態で
自分で自分をコントロールできない状態で心が痛いことはこの子はわかるでしょうに
じゃあその状態はどうやって直せますか？と
教えればそれだけのことで
それ終わっちゃうんです
ですから 道徳も科学的に教えるべきものなんです
それには必要なのは体のことだけ勉強するんじゃなくて
人間というのは体と心という 2つでできてるんだから
50%ばっかしなんでやってるんですか？それこそ非科学的なんです
50%のことを勉強してないんです
ですから もう歴史やらもう地理学で科学で全部もう数学やら全部そればっかりなんです
でも人間は死ぬまで生きていなくちゃいけないんです
仕事は 50歳で  60歳で終わっちゃうし
それまた 21歳  2歳  3歳から始まるものだから
ほんの短いってことでしょうに
ただそれだけに全ての教育を縛ってるんだから
だからいつでも教育論で言いましたけど
教育っていうのは生まれてから死ぬまでへの生き方を教える道なんです
それとずっと人間っていうのは心で生きているんです
お嫁さんと姑さん喧嘩するのは心の問題であって
お互いに負けたくないとか
それで不幸になるんですけど
別にお嫁さんが悪いわけではないし
自分から見れば娘さんだから大したことないのに
問題は心のところにあるんです
お嫁さんに見えていても
もう問題は心にあるんです
心さえ直せば 全部問題
社会問題やら家庭の中の問題やら
全部解決するんです そういうことで
まあ将来に向けて我々に必要なのは
そういう科学的な道徳であって
違う言葉で言えば心の勉強だ
勉強なんですね で それからまあ大体それぐらいでまあまあ終わっちゃいますけどね
例えば殺すな 盗むなと
よくない行為するな 嘘を言うな
無駄話するな 悪口を言うな
余計な怒りと余計な欲をやめなさいと
邪見盗むなという 10種類の悪いこと
仏教でリストあるんです
でもそのリストよりは
お釈迦様がずっと喋っているのは
なぜ嘘をつくんですか
人間が なぜ人を殺すんですかと
なぜ生命を殺すんですかというと
殺さずにいられない感情があるんですね
で それはどういうものかと
自分の体の中でとんでもない恐ろしい感情が生まれたら
自分どうなるんですかと
それを科学的に勉強してやると
あ こんな考え方は良くないと
すぐ心を清にしちゃうんです
そうすると自然に 盗むことはできなくなっちゃうんで
私はものすごい貧しい育ちでしたから
ないことしかあることはなかったぐらいの経験なんです
学校に行ったんだけど
本はないし テキストはないし
もうほとんどお下がりばっかりやってましたけど
それはボロボロでもうページがなかったとかね
大変苦労していたんだけど
でも一度も店に行ってもどこ行っても物は盗ったことはないんです
ガキ頃でも一回ある店に行って
小さい時 ちょっとした買い物したんですね
そこでその人は両替と両替じゃなくて
何といいますか バランス
なんて言います お釣り
お釣りをくれたんですけど
僕はまあ自分で計算してお釣りをうちに持って行っちゃって
あれ結構多いんですね
多い瞬間でものすごい小さい時なんで
その時はもしかするとまあ 6歳ぐらいだったと思いますけど
あれ？お釣りが多いんだ
あの人間違ってるんだ
これ教えてあげなくちゃと
これ持って行ってはいけないんだと言って
あの これはこれぐらいですけど
これ正しいんですかと
まああんまり計算できなかったんだけど
そこでその人また見たら
ああ あんた本当にすごいいい子ですねとかね
普通の子だったらそのまま持っていっちいますよと
で ご褒美あげますよと飴もらっちゃったんです
ですから 別に人のものを取りたいという欲さえなければ
別に私はいいことをしたと
その時も全然わかってもないんです
あれはいいことだと 僕は正直に
正直な人間にみんなに振る舞ってやろうとか
もう何もないんです あ
ただその人が間違って余分にお金をくれている
これはいけません それだけのことなんです
ですから もう小さい時からもそういう風に私たちに言われたのは
もう怒るなということ
なんで怒ってるんですかと
なぜ欲張るんですかと
で 心の中を教えてくれたんですね
仏教の文化だから 人のものを盗むなというよりは
欲張ることこそがもう汚いんだと
その人が汚くて醜いんだと
それで自分が汚くて醜くなりたくないんだから
美しくなりたいんだから
まあ心の欲 欲っていうのは生まれないようにコントロールする
欲もあるんです 別にどうったこと
私はすごい飴なんか食べたかったんだけど
いっぱい並んでるんだけど
お金がないんですね あ
食べたいなといつでも思ったんだけど
だから言って万引きしようかと全然思ったことがないんです
だから欲はあったんだけど
取るまではいかないんで
そこは汚れたんだ それは汚れた行為だと
他の子供たちもいろいろちょっと小銭盗んだりすることを見たんだけどね
私もやりましょうと思ったことは一度もなかったし
どうして先生はそういう思わないんでしょうかね
小さいのに この教育も受けない
教育  教育も受けないのに
どうしてそういう  だからこの
欲があったとか 取ろうとかね
思わないんでしょうか
だからそれもう一つポイントなんですけど
あの その心の方を見られるように
自分のことを見られるように
小さい時からも道徳っていうのは生まれた時
すぐその時からも教えるものなんです
人間 死ぬまで教える 勉強するものなんです
ですから 小さい時からもうこれやっておかないと
形でやるものでも小学生でやるものではないんです
そこなんです ですから
小さい時 もう可愛がってばっかしで
構うばっかしで 何も善悪判断を教えておけなかったら
もう人間の爆弾なんです
ですから それはもう小さい時からもうやらなくちゃいけないことなんです
先生のご両親がいろいろ教育されたんですか？ まあ
向こうもだいたい誰でも同じことで
特別ではなくてね だから仏教はお釈迦様の初期仏教の文化でしたから
まあそれはもうミャンマーにしたっても同じことであって
まあ小さい時からもうこの心を磨くこと
心清らかである 体だけ綺麗ではダメやと
綺麗っていうのは 心は綺麗
体も綺麗っていうことですよっていうことは
もうごく普通な考え方で
もうずっとやってるんです
ですから そういう仏教の国々では
仏教は勉強してないんです
こんなもうもうしちめんどくさい
難しい仏教なんか このおばあちゃんたちがおじいちゃんたちも全然知らない
パーリ語も知らない 知らないんだけど
人間に一番必要な道徳っていうのは徹底的に科学的に知ってるんです
だから それをなぜかでお釈迦様はしっかり教えたんだから
それだけはもう消えないと
それでも失敗いっぱいありますけど
犯罪消えたわけじゃないんですけどね
それはまた人間の弱みであって
まあそれは別に まあそれは別なところで扱いますけど
で 次にこのお釈迦様思った
この自由に考えましょうという立場
人は自由に考えなくてはならない
ということは 人間に自由があるということなんですね
で 自由に考えて自分で判断すれば正しいことになっちゃうんです
このあなたは自分で考えなさいと子供たちに言っても
また問題があるんです
あれ 無責任じゃないかと
あんた 自分で判断しなさい
自分で考えなさい 言ってもいくらか無責任なんですね
そこは単なる自由な考え方が正しいということでもないんです
で それで子供にあんた方は自分で考えて自分で判断しなさいと言われたりする
そうすると 子供はどんな反応しますかと
わかりません 自分で その場合
どうすればいいんですかね
その時はまあ こちらが自由に考えなさいっていうのは当たり前なんですが
相手が判断するのは相手の権利ですけど
相手わかりません まだ未熟だから
その時は我々は長いに
今まで私は否定してきた
長い文明の中で 歴史の流れの中で
我々は試行錯誤で何がいいか
何が悪いかという長い経験
我々は持ってるんです
大人が それで あ それだったらまあ昔はこういうことがあったと
聖書にはこういう風にあるんだと
仏典ではこういう風にあるんだという風に教えてあげる
そうすると本人がはい
わかりました 私で判断しますということになるんです
ですから 古い知恵は知識は捨てたものでもないし
それなりに試行錯誤で間違ったり
もうやってみて またトライアルアンドエラーでやってきて残っているものだから
そちらには結構知恵があるんです
そんなものはそのまま鵜呑みにして信じちゃ信じるんじゃない
信じたら全然道徳にならない
なぜならば ずっと人間間違ってきたんだから
そうじゃなくて まあ自分で判断できない
だから じゃあこういうこういうものは参考にすればどうですかと
仏典も参考にする 聖書も参考にする
他の宗教の教えも参考にしてみる
哲学者の考え方も参考にして
自分で考える  そこで我々は子供たちにちゃんとしたこのいろんな情報を与えてあげる
で 与えてあげたら 子供たちが自分で納得して
自分で判断してしたら
もうそれで終わりです
その子はその言ったことを守るようになっちゃうんです
あの次にこの語り方 これイエス様失敗しましたから
だから殺されたでしょう
で 語り方なんですね で
そこをすごい気をつけなくちゃいけない
人間の言葉っていうのは
いつでもすごい極論になっちゃうんですね
例えば人を殺してはいけませんと
もう全部結論出してるんです
そういう風にもう結論で喋ってはいけないんです
全部最初から決める 決まりつけて
どんなことも同じこと
例えば人間は自由ですという言葉あるでしょ
もう結論なんです それ言ってみてください
誰かに頭のいい子供たちに
大人に言ったって意味がないんですけど
人間は自由ですよと言ったら
子供はどう反応しますか？あの
あの この問題に現れた子供のような子供に言ってみてください
なぜ人を殺してはいけませんかということに
人間は自由です と言ってみたら
じゃあ自由だから私は何やったっても関係ないんだと
自由だから そちらに反論があるんです
だからいい加減に人間は自由ですとと言ってはいけません
言葉気をつけなくちゃいけない
で 例えばまたよく人気ある言葉なんですけど
人間は平等ですよと 人間は平等
先生言っちゃったら子供たちに
子供たちはどう反応すればいいんですか？じゃああんた偉そうに何で我々を教えるんですかと
平等でしょうと その場でその言葉否定しちゃうんです
大人が偉そうにね まあ人間は平等ですよとすごいこと言ってると思ってるんですけど
言ってるつもりですけど
でも現代の子供たちっていうのは
もし反論しちゃったら
じゃあそれだったらなんであなた方偉そうにあれしなさい
これしなさい あれやっていけない
いい加減にしなさい 我々は平等だから
あなたも私も同じです
言っちゃったら終わり
なんであなた方はタバコ吸ってもいいし
我々吸ってはいけない
平等だと 我々も吸いますと
そこで同じく自由に考えなさいということも同じく自由に考えなさいと言ったところでどうなるんですか？じゃあ私はもう好き勝手に考えますからと
ですから その言い方が良くない
で だいたい今の教育的な
この今の現代文化社会では
人間にはほとんど自由がないんです
教育は決まってて 社会システム決まってあって
もう学校に行く服の色まで決まってあって
会社に行く服の色まで決まってあって
もう決まって の中でも決まり決まり
もうほとんど自由はないんです
全くない状態になってますし
ですから このそれでまた問題が出てくるんです
ですから こちらで全部考えているんだと
あんた方は言う通りにやればいいと
今 子供たちには 若者に現代人に言っているのはそういうことなんです
全部システムは前もって決まってるんだ
考えてるんだと あんた方は決まってる通りにやればいいんだと
で そう言われちゃうと
自分で考えることは不可能になっちゃうんですね
なっちゃうだけじゃなくて
前言ったように この余裕が出ちゃうんです
頭に そこでもう妄想しちゃうんですね
ですから お釈迦様はどういうふうに言ったかというと
前も言ったように なんち自分で考えようと
なんじ自分で考えよ 私は知らんよと言ってないんです
道徳のことはなんち自分で考えよ
わしは知らんと そうじゃなくて
考え方を教えてあげるんですね
このように自由に考えるんだと
道順 これちょっと説明しましょう
例えば自由に考えましょう
でもくだらないことを考えるな
自由ですけど くだらないことを考えるな
自分の不幸になることを考えていけないと
自分のためになること
みんなのためになることを考えましょうと
自由に考えましょう でも
悪いことを考える必要はない
苦しいんだと 頭の中ですっごい悪いことばっかり考えてよくないです
ですから 明るいことを考えましょうと
ですから この人は考えるのは自由だと言いながら
ちょっと指導してあげるんですね
そうでないと世の中成り立たないんです
車運転と同じなんです
自分の車だから 自分好きな通り運転してもいいんだけど
運転には仕方があるんです
運転してもいいんだけど
こういう風に運転しますよと
我々 何か電気製品 新しい電気製品買ってきましたと
コンピューター買ってきたんだと
使うのは自由ですけど
使い方があるんです 動け動けとコンピューター持ってもうぶったたいたって動きませんし
で 使い方があるんです
でも使うのは自由です
ですから 使うのはあなた買ったんだから
あなたのものだから あんた自由に使ってください
使い方こういうものだよと言わなくちゃいけない
そういうふうにこの喋る場合は
言葉は気をつけてほしい
で 仏教以外あまり見当たらないんで
そういうふうに気をつけて
喋るということは急に殺すなかれ
ただそれだけ でわからなくなっちゃう
殺すなかれと ダウシャルトノットキルと出てくるんです
と言ってもみんな殺してるんです
ですから そういうふうに命令文句で決まり文句で言わないで
ちゃんと条件つけて こういうふうにというふうに言わなくちゃいけない
ですから お釈迦様は決して命令していないんだけど
まあ大雑把な言葉で人間は自由である
人間は平等である ああだこうだともないんです
いわゆる基本的には 生命としてはすべての生命は平等なんですが
鳥は鳥で人間は人間ですよと
あるお経でこのあのブッダの言葉という経典日本訳もあります
そこであのワーセットスッタかなだと思いますけど
お経ありますから 読んでみたらありますけどね
いかに人間は平等であるかということを教えているところなんです
お釈迦様はすごくあるバラモン人に怒って
バラモン人だけ偉いと言われたら何言うんですかと
人間はバラモン人の女見たっても
シュードラカーストの低いカーストの女の人見たっても
みんな子供を産むことも
子供を作ることも おっぱいあげる全部同じでしょうと
食べるものでも何でもでも
でも鳥と動物見たら違いますと
鳥と獣見たら鳥は飛ぶへと
獣はもう動物の中で植物の中ではちゃんと生命差別はあるんだと
差別と区別があるんだと
人間にはないんだと 人間もスペーシスとして
種類として 1種類ですよと
鳥はいろいろあって いろんな獣あって
同じく人類というホモサピエンスと 1種
ホモサピエンスという言葉を使ってないんですけど
1種類ですよと その中でも 1種類は 1種類だけど
嘘つきは嘘つきだと バラモン人じゃないんだと
人のものを盗る人は泥棒やとバラモン人じゃないんだと
シュードラ人でもないんだと
で そこでまたちゃんと条件つけて喋るんです
いかに素晴らしく喋っているかということなんです
で 次にこのまあもう時間飛びましたけど
一番大事なポイントはこれからなんです
であの 生命って何ですか？と
何のために生きてますか？という問題に答えが出さないとしっかりした道徳にならないんです
一体全体生命って何ですか？もう一つ忘れたことがあるんです
仏教の道徳っていうのは
単なる人間だけの道徳ではないんです
生命に対する道徳なんです
人間に喋ったんだから
人間の方がたくさん言ってるんです
でも 人のものを盗んだら動物もひどい目に遭うんです
動物の世界でも怒ったら同じ結果なんです
互いに嫉妬したり怒ったりしたら
動物の世界を見てください
話になっちゃうんです
だから良くないんだと
植物の場合も同じことなんです
ですから 植物のことはあまりそこまで言わないんだけど
一応生命に対して喋ってるんです
まあ科学だからしょうがないし
科学も人間だけじゃないでしょうね
全部生命一つにして喋ってるし
そこでこの ですから 生命って何ですか？何のために生きているんですかと
という問題に答えがあるならば
まあ道徳っていうのは別に問題ではないんです
そこら辺ちょっと考えた方がいいんです
そこから始めなくちゃいけないんです
で いきなり神に創られたとかね
ただ自然に現れたとかね
そんなことを言っちゃったら
自然に現れたんだったら自然の法則で何でもいいやってことになっちゃうし
神に創られたんだって言ったら
まあ神に任せちゃえばいいっていうことになるし
お釈迦様は厳しく この絶対的な神を信じることはあるところで
道徳の世界だけで厳しく批判するんです
道徳壊れるんだと 神の概念を持ってきたら
こう言うんです すべては絶対的な神に決められているんだと
絶対的な神に創造されて
人間のすべてが神に決められているんだと
絶対的でと 全知万能であると
神は過去 現在 未来 すべて知っているんだとと言ったならば
どうなるかというと それだったら人は人殺すことも神が知っていて
神に計画であると 神の計画であると
盗むことも神の計画であって
別に人間はどうったことは人間は何もしなくてもいいんだと
神が決まってるプログラムでやってるんだと
で 道徳が消えるんだと
だからその概念こそは間違っているんだと
世の中を見たらそうじゃないと
それだけはもう否定しているんです
で それで今日言いたいのは
この問題ね 生命はなんですか？なんで生きてるんですか？っていう問題に答えがあればいいんだけど
それすごい難しいんですね
生命って何ですか？何のために生きてるんですかと
難しいでしょ？一生かかっちゃうんです
それ理解するために 例えば
ものすごい我々の立場から言えば
すごく瞑想して もう存在って何ですか？とことん理解しなきゃもう出てこないんです
だから大変な ことなんです
でもそこまで道徳を守らなくてもいいっていうことにはならないんです
ですから そこは一生の問題として置いておいて
我々は何のために生きているかということは
とにかく死ぬ前にいつか見つからなくちゃいけないということに置いておかなくちゃいけない
で ですから言えるのはこういうこと
で 何のために生きているかということはわかりま
今はわかりませんだけど
それ私の一生の課題だよと
とにかく善しからしから生きているんだと
それだけわかりますね
まあ何のためであろうか
生きていることだけ事実なんですね
それだったらどのように生きるべきかということ
何のために生きるかということは
もう一生の課題 その以前
もう善し悪しから生きているんだから
じゃあその中でどのように生きるべきかと
それを勉強しなくちゃいけないと
そういうことで 問題にこっ
問題に答えが出る以前からも
道徳を守らなくちゃいけないんです
本当に道徳を解決するのは
何のために生きているかということを発見した時は
道徳は成立する でも そこまで守れませんと言っちゃったら困るんです
ですから とにかく今あんた生きてるんだから
どのように生きるべきかと
あなたはどのようにこの社会の中に生きるべきかと
今瞬間の今も瞬間生きているんだから考えなくちゃいけないんです
だから道徳というのは
すなわち生き方ですね
生きる道 生き方にある特別な違うものじゃないんです
生きる時はそういうことをやりませんってことではないんです
普通の人間で生きている間
嘘を言わないことをしますと
盗もうしないことをしますではなくて
生きることそのものが道徳なんです
仏教では ですから 生き方
それで仏教から言えば歩き方もあります
座り方あります 服の着方もあります
全部あります きめ細かく
歩く時も決まってる法則でないと歩いちゃうと良くないんだと
ただ嘘を言うなだけじゃないんです
歯磨が歯を磨けと 顔を洗えと
そこまで言ってるんです
部屋をちゃんと掃除しろと
特に出家の場合は自分の部屋ということはない
集団のサンガの部屋ですから
建物だから ですから 自分が部屋に入ったら
部屋の家具はどこにあるか
全部チェックして あ ここはここはこここうやって自分が使って
それから終わると全部掃除して
あった場所は全部元に戻しておいて
部屋を出なくちゃいけない
それも道徳なんです それであの財産守る人はいなかったのに
仏教の中でも結構お寺に財産があるんです
でも盗まない その場で置いとくんです
そこまでものすごい厳密に道徳どこぐらいありますかと
インドであるスリランカでもトイレに行ったら水を使うんです
体を洗うために で 水を使うとあちこち水を散らかしちゃうでしょうに
そうすると 次に行く人にとってはちょっと気持ち悪い
当たり前なの ですから
トイレに行ったらどのように水を使うべきかと
そこも書いてるんです
あちこち散らかしちゃいけないませんと
自分取った水を全部捨てて
この水を入れる 使う入れ物あります
それを繰り返しておいて戻りなさいと
一滴の水も人が前の人が使った水が残らないようにと
その代わり 水を入れる場所があって
そこを水が少ないなとわかったら
見えた人が水を入れなさいと
ほこりを見た人 見つかった人が掃除しなさいと
膨大な量があります それは出家に対して
それは普通の常識なんです
から どういうことだ 人殺すなかれってそんなもんじゃないんです
どのように生きるべきかという
すべて道徳なんです そこを忘れているんです
そういうこと それからすぐにまた仏教
次の生命っていうのは個なんですね
個人ですね 私は私で あなたはあなたという個人なんです
個人個人でできている
細胞とない細胞 一つ一つ独立なんですね
生命体に必要なすべて細胞に入ってるんです
欠けているものは何もないんです
で 私といえば 私 人間として完全に必要なものは全部そろってるんです
そういうまた問題あるんです
だからといって純粋に独立した個人かというとそうじゃないんです
他の生命がなければ その個人で生きていられないんですね
だからみんな個人だよというそういう大胆な言い方言い方言ってないんです
個人であるありますが
すべての生命の中で そのシステムの中で総合的な関係あって生きているんだと
細胞を見たらすぐわかるでしょうね
細胞一個っていうのは完全にすべてできているんです
必要なものは全部揃っているんです
核があって その中で全ての DNA が遺伝子が入ってあって
何も問題ない でも人間の細胞を外へ出してみてください
死んじゃうでしょうに
ですから 細胞が他の細胞と関係があって生きているんです
そこで私という個人も
すべての人間の関係があって生きているんです
それを理解してほしいと
ですから 他がなければ個が成り立ちませんと
で 生命というのは互いに依存していますが
まああるまたある面では個人であると
その論理 それまた事実でしょうに
それは事実ですね 細胞と同じで
細胞個は完璧にもうできているんだけど
他の細胞とコンタクトないと死んでしまっちゃう
我は私は個人でもう完璧なんですが
他の人間が他の生命が消えちゃったら私もさようならと
植物がないと 他の動物がいないと
人間がいないと 私一人も終わりと
だから幸福になると みんなで幸福にならなくちゃいけないし
不幸になるとみんな一斉に不幸になってしまっちゃうんです
だから互いに迷惑かけないにかけないこと
互いの幸福を願うことは当たり前の論理になっちゃうんです
私の体の細胞一つわがままになったならば
それ癌でしょうね 私は勝手に増えますと思ったら
それは癌でしょ それで私は死ぬでしょうに
だから道徳を守らない子が社会の癌なんですね
そうなってはいけないんですね
そういうことで 道徳を守るべきっていうのは
仏教でも当たり前のこと
人は呼吸するような感じで
もう何言うんですかとということで言っていることです
個人は成り立たないんです
他なければ だからどうやって
どんな訳で他を殺すんですかね
なぜ人を殺してはいけないかといったら
その人がなければあなたないんですよという答えでしょうに
あなたここにいることはその人いることですよと
そこはすごい知識的に科学的に教えてないんです
だからその子供にわからない
なんで殺してなくてはいけないのと
わからないけど その子は考えてるんですよ
だからあんた方は平気で人を殺して悪いこと言って
まあ嘘を言うなってことを言ってるんだとは言ってるんだと思いますけど
まあそれはそれで で ですから
個人には 個を守る義務があるんですね
私には私を守る義務があり
同時に他を守る義務もあるんです
なぜならば 他がなければ私は守れませんだから
ですから わかりますか？個人には子を守る義務があって
その子には他を守る義務がありますから
子には自殺する権利はないんです
自分を殺してやると それは権利ないんです
自分のものじゃないんです
体が 細胞一行はもう勝手に行動してはいけないんです
ということで 自殺はありえない
自殺すること自体は非道徳的なんです
みんなのことを馬鹿にしているんです
自分だけのことを考えているんです
一般的な常識でいえば
子供は勝手に自殺するんだけど
その親がどう感じるかと考えたことあるんですかね
一生懸命育てたのに ご飯食べさせて洗って
お風呂に入れて いろいろいろんな服を着替え着替えたり
いろんなことをやったりして苦労して
平気でなんか自分勝手な命だと思ってるんだから
もういいから自殺すると
ですから これ私だけの命じゃないんだと
みんなでよくやってくれて
こんなふうにしてあげたんだから
私もそれなりにもう行動しなくちゃいけないということを
でもこういうことも言います
社会にも役に立たない
全く自分にも役に立たない時には
その時はいろんな延命措置を入れて入れて入れて
それでも 1分でも2分でもとにかく生きていきたいと
生きることはすっごい苦しいんだけどと
自分にとっても 例えば末期状態になってベッドにいる
ものすごい もう苦しい
ご飯も食べられない 喋れない
もう頭ももう動かないと
それでももう生きていきたいと
もう他人にもすごい迷惑と
単なる物体が生きているということは
やっぱりここから この立場から見れば意味がないんです
ですから 本人に自分の意思で
延命措置なんかはどうぞ外してくださいと
いりませんと もうこの体は役に立たないんだと
私にはもうあと 1 日いたってもあまり意味がないんだと
だから自然に死にますと
という権利はあるんです
それは別に非道徳的な行為じゃないんです
で でも だからといって私には安楽死はね
医者が決めて親族が決めることはどうかはわかりません
人の命のことを決めることはできないんだから
やっぱり本人が決めるんだったら
別にそれは自殺ではありません
それは社会に対して 自分に対しても親切な行為なんです
ですから  最終的にはね
私の命っていうのは 私個人の命っていうのはみんなの命ですよと
それはみんなのものですよと
ということで  私もそれなりに幸福になって
みんなも幸福になるように私の人生設計しますと
私も楽しく みんなも楽しくなるように頑張りましょうという
やりましょうと 生きることは
そこがもう最終的に人々は決めるべき生き方なんです
そうすると 生きるためにこの努力する気合が入っちゃうんですね
私だけの命じゃないんだと
例えば試験を受けなさいというと
自分のためだしと言ってるでしょう
子供たちに なんか気合が入らないんですね
まあどうせ最後にはもう意味ですからという風になっちゃうし
ですから 命というのはものすごい大きなシステムでできているものなんです
ですから まあ自分がよく頑張ったら
もうやっぱりよく意味があるんだと
他の人々もそれなりにもう大変幸福になるんだというと
やる気が出てくるんです
落ち込まないです で 次のもポイントだけしか言えませんだけど
で 我々学校で生命っていうのは進化していますよと教えられたんですね
この学校で教えられた進化っていうのは
この物体の形の変えたことなんです
進化ではないんです でしょ
結局進化論っていうのは
この体って物体の形が変わるんだと
まあ大したことじゃないです
それだったら 例えば将来人間はまるっきり歩かなく歩かなくて
何か道具を使うようになったと
歩く時は足に何か車でもついちゃって
それでどこでも歩くようになっちゃった
足がいらなくなっちゃうんです
それはそんなにことじゃないんです
で 仏教から言うのは まあ物質は変化する
進化というよりは いろいろ形は変化する
もう適当な形にいつでもなっちゃうんです
それはそんなに不思議なことじゃないんです
このマイクロフォンにこんな形あるのは
こういう形が適当だからなんです
それなりに形になる 体の形もそうなります
で 心も進化するんだと
だから体だけじゃないんだと
今私に心がある じゃあ
この心を進化することは私の大変な大事な仕事だとと言って
一生懸命心の進化のために努力するということは必要なんです
心の進化のために努力する人は
わずかな道徳も犯せませんね
心の分析やってますから
その人 ですから 心の進化になることは何でもやると
心清らかになることは何でもやると
心汚れるものは全然やりませんと
そういうようなことを成り立ちます
ですから あの聖書で書いているんだからやらないというのは道徳ではない
ブッダが言ってるんだからやらないっていうのは道徳じゃない
それは生き方だから 生きることだから
やりますと それは道徳なんです
ですから まああの人間というのは大体いろいろ美しく生きると
醜く汚く生きるんじゃなくてね
美しく生きると 小さい時からもう道徳という小さい時からもしなきゃいけないんです
まだ美しく綺麗に生きてましょうと
綺麗っていうのは体も綺麗で
心も綺麗で生きること
ですから 人に挨拶するときはすごく美しいんです
せ 電車で座席をおばあちゃんに
あるいは弱い人にあげることはすごく美しいですよと
その人の行動も美しいし
心も美しいんだと ですから
道徳と美学を合体させておけば
美しい道徳論が成り立っていると思います
そういうことで話終了しますけど
釈尊の道徳論というのは
そういうすごいしっかりした科学的な合理的なもので
信仰と脅しはないと 信仰と脅しがあると
みんなはっきりやっていないと
それが今までの人々はしっかりと納得いけるところまで教えてくれなかったと
だからずっと歴史上の中で人間は道徳を犯してきましたと
ですから 私は最終的に言いたいのは
人殺しは悪いというならば
たとえどんな理由があっても悪いと
イラクは戦争したことも悪いし
それに爆弾かけた人々も悪いと
犬が自分を噛んだんだから足を噛んだんだから
人間もサッといて犬の足を噛むことは正しいんですかね
私の足を噛んだら 私も君の足を噛みますよと
それはけしからんな もう醜い生き方でしょうに
犬はもう自分の足を噛んじゃったら
もうそこは犬のところに行かなきゃいいのに
犬をからかわなけりゃいいのに
それだけのことでしょうに
気を付ければいいでしょうに
そういうことで悪いものはいかん
かなる理由があっても悪いというふうに決めるぐらい説得力が必要なんです
以上でございます 長い間ありがとうございます